is Mariah Carey hurting and depressed
after the broken engagement with her
billionaire fiance that's the new report
out there well guess what you can judge
for yourself because we have Mariah's
first interview and performance since
their bombshell breakup alright knowing
I'm good how are you look fantastic how
you feeling thank you very festive
Mariah showed up about an hour late and
was reportedly paid $500,000 per song
that would make her near 7-minute to
song performance at Saks Fifth Avenue's
Toronto holiday window unveiling a
million dollar payday
Mariah lout absolutely no personal
questions about her billionaire ex James
Packer but et Canada's Roz Weston found
out breakup songs may be in the works
are you writing new music for a purpose
or you're writing new music for any
album right now I'm writing new music
right now yeah I'm in the mud I just
recorded a vocals for this one song and
I'm really excited about what's the
what's the vibe where's your head at
musically right I can't tell you you can
see Mariah's rumored fling backup dancer
Bryan Tanaka was there and she still has
that so-called 10 million dollar
engagement ring it's now on her right
hand but it kind of seems like Mimi
didn't quite know what to do with it
during the performance it was on her
ring finger then during the interview
maybe switched it to her middle finger
she just kept playing with the rock
which gotta say is one giant expensive
MIDI ring if you gotta take a picture
I'll pose for you and while the
billionaire may be out of her life a
source close to Dame's told us there's
very little chance of reconciling riot
is still diva supreme it's so close to
him back up uh uh it's just killing me
softly oK you've had cameras in your
live for a while now with the
docu-series
yeah was that going I've had cameras in
my life longer than that but this is
like is it does this feel different than
what you're you it felt even in the
beginning and I was a little more like
withholding in the beginning and now I'm
kind of just like I'd rather be myself
and let people see what that is because
that's the purpose of the whole thing